raisi I'd never got into robbing cars
cause they're in love awesome buddy
we used to rob car stereos but at one
point cars started putting a device that
that if he stole the stereo wouldn't
work at another car I think especially
Subaru I can tell you what I first
started working for Subaru it was 1986
it was really I was living in Boulder
and I was a detailer but I became
friends with the manager's name was
Peter Pinto real street guy and one day
he's like why do you wash gosh do you
like one of the best salesmen just
property I can buy [ __ ] from you and he
goes just come over on a Monday to see
if you like it and I came home with a
Monday so three cars a million thousand
bucks
at that time I used to work 60 hours a
week for like washing I think it was 860
a month they would pay me again you made
in a day I'm making a day selling cars
in a wet I borrowed five hundred from my
girlfriend's mother and I went and
bought you know three jackets three pair
pants a pair of shoes and bail and I
went and [ __ ] locked and [ __ ] dead
but I thought I was making like 7 to 10
grand a month
mmm that's my first four months in 1987
going to school seven grand a month
Subaru's selling 10 cars a month you
could have been better check from them
you're gonna check from Subaru but the
lot man
drove like a [ __ ] like an expensive
BMW and I'm like how can a [ __ ] lot
man
so you know have a BMW I mean what kind
of white man make you know the year went
by I stayed a loyal employee you know I
got to a few arguments there I
threatened the [ __ ] break the car
with an axe window if they didn't pay me
and [ __ ] like that but the cops came in
one day this was a crazy place where I
worked it was called crowd Subaru yeah
Krauts and that's German or ouch they
have their routes on today they are you
gonna get [ __ ] robbed or some Azia Oh
uch they anunnaki restored today yeah a
couple of Acura stores but in those days
that Subaru store was a [ __ ]
accommodate like it was economy and they
didn't have a lot of Subarus if people
who know what that was ya know in
Colorado
silver is camo on car it's normal
cards it used to be Bert Subaru well the
number one super dealer in the world Wow
they did 500 new Subarus or a [ __ ]
month or something and then we were like
number eight in the district but one day
the cops came and they arrested this
[ __ ] lock guy yeah he was running a
scam at the gym hmm but what we also
didn't know what is that after you sold
a car he would talk to you for five
minutes about your car and he would
upsell how he's selling so this
[ __ ] was taking the stereos out
of the GL ten sedans they're not and
putting in your shitty car so all these
people paying twenty grand for these
high-end cars and the radio since I got
AM radio huh and broke he did it to
every fight like when he got arrested he
had been doing this for years like
people were buying that kind of money
ton of money he was selling rims tires
then it cops came in again one guy and
surrounded the building because we had a
Salesman that used to rob banks at
lunchtime oh wow name was Carlos
Valverde a great idea and he would mind
kids nine [ __ ] kids he Han with the
same wife he had been married like
thirty [ __ ] years ago a banana [ __ ]
as well thirty years he was like twenty
two scan is conveyed there let me forget
this guy one day the [ __ ] cops came
and surrounded the building he was
[ __ ] robbing banks as once that him
and four other guys would [ __ ] get
caught I mean it was [ __ ] crazy then I
got in trouble there like this car
dealership was a professional great
sitcom everybody's stealing home and
behind there was a guy in there that was
in probation because he robbed banks
mhm and then and he was he just got a
jail doing 20 years for robbing banks
the manager was a biker that would work
six months of the year yeah I cut his
hair and shave and he was a great
salesman than the other half of the year
he was a biker hmm didn't do no drugs he
hated drugs and he hated the smell of
vinegar Wow so when I didn't want him
there
I would come in and I buy a bottle of
white vinegar and I take a cap and put
in the corner of his office to spill it
and he'd be in the office
ten minutes he'd be like it's no bigger
and he [ __ ] leaned I used to get coke
bindles and tie like fish wire tool
mm-hmm I throw him on the floor by him
and I'd roll my CD [ __ ] trying to
step on it I had a great time sound so
much fun but it's so funny because what
I learned that year I still do to write
like all the things I learned about
selling cars and how you should be a
Salesman like I still use those
principles today mmm like they would
kept me alive in the comedy game yeah
you know it's good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one